[Musique]
allez pas
pas
à l'essai depuis
[Musique]
j'ai vu la nouvelle danse merci d'être
avec nous beinheim est la plus belle des
nike est la plus belle des filles quant
à l'enquêté l'appareil
oui je suis comme je suis allé voir ou à
l'abri qu'est-ce qui se passe star de
télé internationales oui voiture qu'est
ce que tu me débrouille toi j'ai une
enquête en cours sur le terrain ce week
end
je suis tombé sur une vidéo qui m'a fait
mourir de rire c'est un mec qui
regardent tranquillement des meufs sur
un stade
sauf que le mec derrière lui barrent
garder comme non ya pas sa femme il ya
un miroir et sam après les troubles un
petit conseil faites attention également
aux savoirs histoire faites attention
également si vous êtes par exemple à
côté d'une vitre noir et que vous êtes
comme ça que votre portable
il ya tout qui s'affiche derrière donc
voilà si vous êtes dans la nuit à côté
wade a bien sûr bah oui une vitre tous à
couillet un reflet frère tu es mort
terminé merci au revoir rideau tu
regardais quoi je regardais des fesses
les préfets sac ou c'est pas les faits
sa maman non mais ça c'est sûr et
certain
c'est pas les paye sa maman j'ai dû
crois que tu es
jamais ces je suis de pause lépi après
les dangers
[Musique]
ils résultats d'une enquête sur
l'hygiène des français pendant le
confinement et ben c'est pas joli joli
regardez si on a les mains propres on a
le flip salle beinheim était une super
copine médaille et ma super copine rien
tu me dit david guetta show dance tu me
dis juste david geerts est mise en
évidence la personne c'est un truc tôt
jeudi juste le dos unis david guetta
zones denses et parler ça a pris dix ans
avec en plus moi mon cousin s'appelle
d'alice d'état un médecin il est médecin
il s'appelle david guetta c'est à dire
rien à voir je dirais les mecs quand il
boit d'arriver chez lui ça va c'est pour
une pneumonie
[Musique]
[Rires]
18h38
[Musique]
et on va parler
la télé a oui oui beinheim c'est la plus
belle des pics beinheim
oui c'est la plus jolie ils m'ont dit
est ce que tu peux nous parler plus
belles l'aide alors ça se passe à
marseille tu vois chironi et c'est dans
un quartier de marseille et dans le même
quartier il ya des meurtres des
épidémies des pandémies des malades des
gens des gens ils ont un taux de chômage
plus que dans toute la france qu'ils ont
ils ont un café mon frère qui s'appelle
le mistral ya un cas c'est mon frère
mais dans ce café le café ils ont eu un
cambriolage
huit vols 4 mais qd on va payer à un
cévenol
ils ont eu frère le tout les mecs tous
les mecs de villages tous les mecs de la
rue ils travaillent tous au mistral
ça veut dire leur but ultime est de
travailler dans le café bouna nous on
est fort quand on veut dire qu'il va se
passer quelque chose dans l'émission
plus belle la vie ils sont bien plus
forts que nous parce que chaque soir à
la fin il met un petit peu l'épisode du
lendemain et frère et à chaque fois il
arrive comme à sepang il faut que je te
fasse
six faces sandy a eu un
on est vraiment bien sans elles la
finale de top 16 et andenne jeures
achtung achtung
et oui des épisodes ont été raccourcies
et oui il ya des épisodes ils sont
arrivés b maison à plein rabbin mimi
deza circoncis les pilotes et partisans
- karabagh
c'est le rabbin du paf voilà la bande
avant la fin du papy d'arrivée il a
circoncis toutes les émissions et vas-y
et on voit la taille il accéléré si
collomb tari la circoncision ici d'un
seul conseiller top chef il a un travail
fou cela le jeu de la chance était
présenté par amex appelé raymond
marcillac
c'était le nikos de l'époque raymond
marcillac salut nous c'est vraiment
comment ça va les loups très bien seul
toulouse c'est vraiment marcillac ou ses
cassettes casimir tunisien c'est très
ému mais monsieur trichet
j'ai demandé ma part il est caché ce
père patrick
je peux parler les minutes défilent et
les parties on est vraiment rien
sans elle qu'on soit noir ou blanc et
les mecs c'est ramadan demain ouais
ramadan demain alors bas comme demain je
suis pas je t'aime et bah j'en profite
pour souhaiter un bon ramadan à tous nos
amis voilà voilà on a sauvé la baraque
il a souhaité bien sûr ça a beau être un
mal et s'il yad'autres fait bien entendu
on les souhaits toi j'en crée des faits
créer des fêtes a bien entendu si on le
fait on peut faire voilà un peu on peut
à coupler les deux on peut faire un
ramadan a pesar ça veut dire qu'en fait
vous mangez pas toute la journée et le
soir vont manger des galettes qui vous
font des choix la besa dont le précédent
c'est magnifique benhaim été super
copine benhaim et ma super copine
[Musique]